hi I'm Nick Gillespie I'm with Matt
Welch my reason colleague and co-author
of the Declaration of Independence
how libertarian politics can fix what's
wrong with America
our next question on ask a libertarian
comes from friend of de Rudy
Jason sus burg via Twitter what's a
liberal terian how is it different than
a libertarian Matt liberal terian is
this it's it's a rabbit but it has the
horns of an antelope I know that's a
joke
liberal Terran refers to a headline
written on a brink Lindsey piece that I
believe first ran in the New Republic a
few years back and it was an attempt by
brink Lindsey and will Wilkinson and
some other prominent libertarian
thinkers to find a common language with
which to speak to American liberals and
progressives in particular their
argument was that the historical kind of
Cold War coalition between libertarians
and conservatives who disagree about
quite a lot of things especially as
concerns social conservatism and foreign
policy that that had run its course and
so maybe we should try to come up with a
new you know tentative fusion ISM that
brings libertarians and liberals
together and tries to find common ground
issues like the drug war and some other
things and hopefully move some liberal
ideas on on issues like free trade it
kind of there's a case of bad timing I
think on the project I think has a
long-term project and these coalition's
go I'm all in favor of of spread in the
word to any party who has an ear to
listen but this happened right as we had
the most economic intervention that
we've seen in generations starting with
George W Bush but then continued and
double down now by Barack Obama and so
it wasn't a very receptive climate among
liberals I think at that time to be
howling around with libertarians who
have a pretty strong critique against
the bipartisan interventionism of the
last ten years